bang-bang Austin's here
you're the second newsletter King to
walk in the door this week what's up man
not too much how's it going good I'm
doing great
you're you're doing better than me
you're [ __ ] killing the game over
there morning brew let's start with what
did you do before you became the expert
on newsletters yeah so I actually didn't
do too much this was my first real gig
all right how old are you 25 Jesus
Christ all right you're way more
responsible than I was at 25 go ahead
you've probably heard that a lot yeah so
I was a sophomore college and at the
University of Michigan and a guy by the
name of Alex Lieberman who is my
co-founder now it was writing this like
to even call a newsletter is generous to
email newsletters at least what they are
now it was this crappy PDF attachment
but the way he came up with the idea was
he was helping friends that interview
prep and what he realized was that
people really struggled to resonate with
the business world they were reading the
journal to prep for interviews but they
felt like they had to they didn't feel
like they wanted to read some of these
sources and it's not to discredit these
sources they're all great sources and we
actually you know partner with them were
using them all now but we felt like
there had to be a different take or
different spin on traditional business
news and so Alex started writing that
and at the time there's actually no way
to sign up so you had to email Alex oh
hey I looked over someone else's
shoulders and I saw what they're reading
can you sign me up so after about 300
people did that the list got to 300
which is insanely impressive how he did
that he sent an email for the whole list
saying hey who wants to join and so I
was all in we came together we put it on
hold for a couple weeks
and we launched morning brew at March
15th 2015
why did you come up with that name so
it's funny uh one of Alex's also we were
in the same fraternity both in the AEPi
one of our friends came out of cool one
or not a cool one it's pretty cool
it's like middle of the pack you know
the pack all right that's fine yeah you
don't wanna be to Freddy so like that's
good all right
and what did your friend why did they
come up with this or it was just yes we
knew we knew we're gonna send in the
morning mmm obviously morning that's
where that came from your friends a
genius okay yeah so so you know we're
hitting a home run there and then we
knew that we wanted sign that
represented waking up starting your day
and so coffee starts today the
newsletter starts today and coffee
sounds lame yeah exactly and the funny
thing is I feel like it's like every
name where you hear it you're like oh
that's terrible I hate that name and
then you're like oh that's growing on me
you text 10 friends and like for like oh
that's great six starts like a that's
not that great and then four of those
six come around and we can think this is
better yeah yeah I feel like that I
couldn't think of anything better is a
very common way that names get adopted
yeah I feel like a lot of times you just
pick a running name as you you you have
a big brainstorm you can't come with
anything good today all right this is
the the worst or the best of all the bad
terms well use this is the placeholders
yeah better and this launch day you're
like [ __ ] we never thought of anything
so let's just launch with it I love it
all right so you guys went from 300
subscribers to now you're closing in on
like a million and a half two million
yeah well we get on - okay and how the
hell do you go from 300 subscribers to
almost two million in four years five
years yeah yeah so I join and the answer
is I joined no definitely not was a team
effort so I joined and Alex and I are
the first brand ambassadors at Michigan
so we're going to every econ 101 class
accounting 101 is begging professors you
know can we have three minutes your time
we'd walk into a econ 101 lecture 500
people we'd pitch them on morning brew
and then we'd pass on a piece of paper
with you know 500 lines and every person
would write their email down I don't
think half the people knew what they
were signing up for because they were on
ESPN or they were on Twitter not pay
attention and immediately after that
class we go to landing page and we type
into 500 email addresses I love and we
just go and go and you know we got a few
you know maybe five or six thousand in
Michigan and
really on you know do we read some
entrepreneurship books listen to a few
podcasts do things that don't scale
let's get our friends to this other
schools so we got our friends to do it
and so they all did and they they did a
pretty good job and that got us to
twenty twenty-five thousand maybe and
then we had readers who also want to do
that then we scaled the the Ambassador
Program to readers and we had we this
one ambassador at Notre Dame one of our
first ones who got almost 2,000
referrals Wow yeah so it was a group
effort who was that person she was the
business student and she did the same
thing she had a good relationship with
three even that may three or four
professors and she's a classic yeah huge
classes another day in big business
school like Michigan and if you can get
to an econ 101 class there's 500 kids
there and so it just scaled from that
and so that was the college days
at the very beginning we thought this
was a product for college students so we
thought okay here's a problem people in
college struggled to resonate with the
business world and their knowledge base
in the business world is completely
different than someone who's even a year
or two out so therefore it's critical of
students quickly what we learned after
we graduate graduate or even before is
that that's not the case and so we said
oh the people outside of college also
need this so let's create this for what
we now call the modern business leader
so college students are part of the
target demographic but it's not solely
demographic what do you think the
breakdown is today I mean you guys
obviously have so many subscribers I'm
assuming majority are not in college
right and then the college students are
kind of coming into this is their first
iteration of how they can learn about
business in their voice yeah so we we
call the the college during the
aspirational reader okay so some pick it
up in in freshman or sophomore year
through older students but I guess most
of them golf to an internship see their
analysts their associate reading it or
what we've heard a lot now is when these
big banks are consulting firms come for
career days we'll do a presentation and
they'll say if you wants to update the
business world read these sources and
morning brew be on that list which is
very cool and a bit funny because that's
why we started morning brew is because
there was nothing like
on the list so to see it on the list now
is pretty wild to see Wall Street
Journal economist New York Times morning
brew that's a pretty wild feeling yeah
absolutely
all right so as you guys begin to
realize hey this is actually like a real
business you and your co-founder both
had done stints on Wall Street kind of
financial service firms most people
would kill for those jobs like what are
you two psychos doing not doing that and
going to do newsletters yeah so I think
that's what my parents thought like whoa
what is this newsletter thing and Alex's
you know Alice's family was the same way
but you're gonna work on email yeah what
is this no my parents were very
supportive as were Alex's family I mean
they were definitely a bit weary and
like a bit concern but they trusted us
and and that was that was excellent that
was great but basically after my junior
year I interned at an investment bank
called Mullis and Alex was tears of
legit place yes it's a fairly good bank
it's a boutique bank you work 100 hours
a week but a lot of people think it's
worth it and you know who knows
and Alex traded mortgages and words
daily and probably eight or nine weeks
into my summer we said you know we want
to be entrepreneurs when a start-up is
at some point why not now we have very
few obligations we had you know no kids
no family no house no mortgage obviously
so let's do it now and and we had a
product and and it's funny in hindsight
it probably wasn't nearly as far along
as we thought well we've thirty thousand
subscribers this is sick that's still
pretty good but yeah it was good until
when two advertisers like hey we'll tell
you 100 bucks for thirty thousand
subscribers and really always to really
scale this thing so that's one side to
raise a bit of money so we 2017 when I
graduated we raised in the angel round
so we raised $750,000 convertible note
and that's all we've raised to date so
when you went to raise that money walk
me through the thought process of why
you wanted to raise money versus not and
then how did you think about pricing the
round and convertible debt versus equity
like did you guys have an opinion all
this or was it like dude we got no
[ __ ] clue what we're doing like let's
go ask somebody for advice like how did
you navigate that especially since you
guys were so young and this was kind of
the first thing
you go to school yes so to take a step
back in 2015 when we first started
morning brew we thought the idea we you
know we said you know if we ever go out
and raise money and do this we're gonna
raise a ton of money at the time if you
know if you remember that was when
Facebook was just you know giving
everyone all this traffic and so people
were raising 100 million dollar rounds
you know multiple hundred men like
they're meat companies literally raising
hundreds of millions of dollars and so
we set out we'll follow suit
the luckiest thing that happened to us
and they're one of the reasons where we
are where we are today is because we had
two years from 2015 to 2017 to see what
happened and what we saw is that that
capital was not gonna return in the way
that these investors our founders
thought it was going to and so in 2017
when we raised we took a way more
conservative approach instead of going
out and raising a three million dollar
seed round we said it let's raise as
little as possible that will allow us to
run the business we knew that while we
were decent writers we could envision
the tone and the style went to Reagan
but we couldn't accomplish that and run
the business you know so we knew it's a
higher writer which we knew wasn't a
cost of money more in generating revenue
so we needed to raise something and we
just talked to people and and
convertible notes were hot and and we
know it's the price around at so we we
picked a convertible note there were
some thoughts 750 a million who knows we
got 750 we stopped and so that was it
and we haven't raised cincin and we're
very glad we made that decision
it allows us to be in the driver's seat
every day you know we're a profitable
media company and we don't have to
double every year because that's what
our previous investors want us to do we
get to grow at the pace you want to grow
at what we think is the most responsible
and we're profitable I think we're going
you know very quickly but we don't have
to be irresponsible and we can embrace
and consider other decisions that
certain companies can so if you have
raised a ton of money opportunities may
come about that may seem small at first
and you said turned those away because
you can only take big bets if used to
sell for quarter of a billion or half a
billion dollars for us you know we get
to evaluate every opportunity and to
certain things that are
scalable or maybe aren't worth a billion
dollars but that we want to do it's
funny because I tell every entrepreneur
no matter how much money you raise
you're gonna spend in 18 months right so
like for a 750 you're gonna try to spend
it in 18 months then if you raised 250
million dollars you're gonna spend in 18
months yeah if you were always like no
way
and I'm like let me show you a bunch of
examples and so what you say there is
hundreds of millions of dollars and two
years later you already knew the
outcomes Yeah right like because they
spend all the money in about 18 months
and it makes sense right investors don't
to invest in the company and have that
money sit on a balance sheet yeah they
can hold it in their own yes
exactly yeah so so that that capital has
to be spent mmm for the most part right
obvious there's exceptions but for the
most part an investor is only invest 100
billion dollars free that for that to
sit there bank account because why are
they doing that and so yeah so it makes
sense that gets spent but that just
increases growth projections increases
expectations and it limits the range of
outcomes so when you raise large rounds
of funding or you know get media
companies I I have this belief that not
universally but for the most part it's
very challenging for media companies in
a short period of time to see venture
backed returns I think media companies
are way better off growing slowly it's
all about the brands so if you grow slow
at first then you can take capital later
on and there's a lot of media companies
who have been doing that recently and
seen great success so bar stool I mean
you know it take like whatever you want
with our content from a business
perspective they built that brand for I
don't know five thirteen years for such
a long time before they raised around
and so they built that brand who knows
but my guess is that if they would have
raised that same amount of capital as a
seed round they would not have been able
to slowly grow build that brand which I
think that's what it took and obviously
they're very successful outcome well
dave was literally handing out physical
free papers yeah in Boston like there's
zero chance that if you were to get him
seven million dollars in 2003 that he'd
still have that money by like 2005
yeah half of it who knows where he would
have put it and the other half he wasted
printing papers yeah yeah and there's a
lot of other examples as well I mean you
know the infatuation while they've
certainly raised capital they've been
around for for a very long time and it's
money I barely knew who they were until
a year ago
now it feels like they're everywhere and
I think they recently raised a huge
round butt and they did raise capital
before but they weren't raising multiple
double-digit million rounds of funding
which they probably could have but they
slowly grew it I think they're doing a
great job and and now they have all
these great business lines I I don't
have no idea how they're doing but it
seems like things are going well they
have a an awesome events business they
have a subscription business they have
it as business so it's a it appears from
the outside it's a great company food
52s in the other one a slow-growth
company again they didn't bootstrap the
whole thing but it took a very different
approach than some other companies and
it feels like to these media companies
as they start to kind of hit their
stride really what they're doing is
they're building brand allegiance and
kind of a rabid fan base right and when
you have that you can monetize it to a
million different ways and that
literally takes time right people have
to figure out who you are they've got to
kind of you earn their trust on a
day-to-day basis day in and day out for
months or years at a time and then you
can kind of hit that inflection point I
think that's kind of what you're talking
about this slow yeah exactly I not
everyone but for the most part again
nothing is universal but I do believe it
is challenging to build a brand in three
years that's not so you can have great
branding right you can have great brand
someone there was a big conversation on
Twitter about this last week you could
have unbelievable branding but you
actually build true brand affinity with
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people in a few years I think it's a
huge challenge and it takes time for
sure and as you guys have grown you now
have the the main newsletter you've
added a bunch of different pieces to it
maybe talk us through about like what
else have you added and what is the
thought process for for kind of adding
to kind of that core offering that you
have yeah so end of 2018 we so we
finished 2018 eight hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers but end of 2018 we
were pretty close there obviously and
and we took a step back and we said what
do we want to do next we're not gonna
lose focus in the corners letter but we
want to do other things and we looked at
what every other media company was doing
and we decided we wouldn't do our own
thing and so everyone was still in video
this that and and we decided we wanted
to focus on more newsletters we thought
that our
tone style format email monetization
everything we do an email was unique and
we thought we could take that to areas
in which people are either interested in
or they work in to better their lives
their career or their interest and so we
decided to launch emerging tech brew I
believe February or March 2019 covers a
I machine learning blockchain you know
emerging technologies that sent out
three days a week
we then mid summer 2019 launched retail
brew covers the retail industry so any
emerging new is really anything that
happens in the retail industry we're
giving you a newsletter three times a
week and then I think August or so we
launch business casual which is our
first podcast hosted by Kenzie grant and
we're really excited about that and then
recently we launched the turnout which
is our politics newsletter so once a
week but we do politics differently so
it's not pure politics its business
meets politics so it's the implications
of what's happening in the political
world in the election how that affects
the business world going forward and
we're continuing to launch new
newsletters we see a lot of white space
in the newsletter space and so I believe
will launch at least one more this year
if not to continue its go down the path
of you wake up in the morning your read
morning brew you're educated in the
general business world but then you're a
retail professional and so at 10:10 a.m.
there's a newsletter at your desk you're
reading at work that's educating you on
the retail industry and then you know
hopefully at lunch listen to business
casual and and if we can progress our
media properties throughout your day we
can fill your day with our tone our
style and we can provide a great
experience both to readers but then also
a full funnel approach to advertisers
and so as you're thinking through this
how do you pick like the next vertical
to go into and paid versus free
newsletters kind of like as you're like
actually building the product itself
like what's the thought process that
goes into this yeah it's a really good
question it's like we think a lot about
so let's first tackle all I do is good
questions on this podcast all sure what
the hell let's let's tackle the first
thing so how do we pick the topic it's a
simple matrix it's a combination of
number one is there enough content to
write
so if it's a one so we if the the
ultimate outcome is a once a week
newsletter right now not that
interesting for us just not not enough
to get us excited it has to be enough
content to are there enough people in
that industry such that we believe we
can crow a vertical you know not that
two million but you know we want
something the hundreds of thousands for
sure and then the advertiser pulled how
many companies want to get in front of
these people and so we just line up
bunch of topics and then we defined a
good writer it's really really
challenging to be a morning brew writer
you have to be knowledgeable about the
area which you're working in you have to
be able to write multiple newsletters a
week and you'd feel right in our tone
and we've interviewed so many people who
are excellent journalists and excellent
writers who work at other publications
but they just can't write in our witty
tone in our style and so it's it's a
Venn diagram of a bunch of different
things and it's challenging to find that
writer and so it's it's a combination of
those things so that's how we decide
what vertical to go into now free versus
paid is a much bigger conversation and
we do plan on launching paid products
but I don't believe for the most part
people pay for news or have a high
willingness to pay for news sure if it's
very niche that's that's one thing I was
like your your newsletter very ignition
you're an expert at it so that makes
sense if I just play an expert on yeah
so that's all you have to do is look
like an actor you'll actually have to
have to be an expert black t-shirt
exactly it's funny normally I'm the one
wearing black t-shirts so I'm glad we
mixed it up plane is sitting in the room
and she knows
most people know this now she gets mad
because I all I own is black shirts
because it's much easier just to wake up
to buy t-shirt on but she also is like
hey we're going to this event can you
like maybe put something else on I'm
like well I would if I had something
else you want me to wear this athletic
shirt she's like mass through the black
t-shirt yeah so so that's me
82 days perfect back to back to free
verse paid so you know again Wall Street
Journal paper record there are
exceptions but we don't have a desire to
ever charge for our core newsletter or
for news for that
I do think when we think about paid we
think about we have this community of
two million-plus modern business leaders
as we call them so aspirational people
out there who are intellectually curious
who want to get better and better
themselves and so how can we bring these
people together how can we educate them
in other ways and that will come with
time but for right now we see so so much
opportunity and so much white space in
the the free ad based media world that
we're playing yeah and so when you look
across a kind of media models today does
a media company need to have these
various revenue sources in order to
actually not only survive but actually
thrive we see a lot of the large media
companies they've pushed hard into
things like live events or subscription
paywalls you know all these other things
outside of just their core advertising
is that a hey we need to do this so we
do it or do you think that's more of
just them being super ambitious and
innovative I think it depends on what
scale you want to get to so at our scale
were 100% at base setting that's fine if
we want to get to a hundred million
dollars of revenue 100 plus I definitely
think we'll need to diversify revenue I
think the goal at some point yeah I
definitely think you know our goal while
we don't have venture money this doesn't
mean we're not looking for venture
outcomes and so we certainly want to get
you 100 million plus in revenue and so
we will diversify revenue I think it
depends if you are a majority ad based
company I do think tacking on other
things is good because ads can be lumpy
it can be challenging to cater source
ads if it explained that a little bit
more right so selling ads I think is
people just like oh I see this ad in
this newsletter
cool whatever some of them are good some
of them are bad but I don't think they
really understand like what goes into
the process of selling the ads like how
did you guys start selling ads and then
like what does that process look like
for you guys today
yeah so ads and newsletters are
different for everyone there are some
newsletters out there who just put live
intent or programmatic ads we do zero
programmatic so everything we source or
they're inbound but we have account
managers from at home as they count we
have brand
partners who were selling we've
integrated marketing who's coming with
full funnel campaigns and so we are
working with partners to understand
their goals to understand their talking
points but we make sure that every ad
unit in our newsletter is native in our
tone in our voice integrated in the
newsletters so we believe editorially we
do a great job and resonate with our
readers with our tone our style our
format and so your ad is gonna be in the
same exact way and so our content
resonates just like your ad will
resonate but yeah I mean some of these
some of these ad partners are big deals
right six seven-figure deals with that
can come lumpiness or variability to the
business and right now everything's
going well but certainly for for us you
know we definitely think about how can
we diversify like I said before we're
really confident but if you're if you're
an ad based business but you're you have
programmatic ads you know I am NOT the
most knowledgeable person on the
programmatic ad industry but obviously
there's lots going on with third-party
cookies and everything and and I think
those businesses are going to look to
how kind of respites were putting up a
paywall
events and some of those things by the
way they're not just small ancillary ad
businesses they could be bigger than the
ad business there are media companies
out there that put on multi-million
dollar events every year so it can be a
great revenue stream when you're selling
the ads how do you guys think about that
relationship with the advertiser do you
look for everyone from hey I'll do one
advertisement one time to kind of I'm
assuming like an annual contract type
relationship or do you try to focus on a
certain type of advertiser and really
what I'm interested in is you guys have
taken a very kind of long-term view of
building the relationship with the the
reader or the modern business leader do
you do the same thing on the advertising
side or is it just the average Heiser
kind of dictates what the terms that
they want and you guys are just trying
to fulfill their needs like how do you
think about that yeah we like to treat
our advertisers as well as we treat our
readers and so obviously as a media
company that's always a balance it's
always the challenging balance we say no
and turndown we actually just did this
we turn it down an advertising partner
because we felt they weren't
good partner for the brands but and is
this because they're like a vise type
thingy you know they're drug related
alcohol related something like that or
more so they weren't a good fit in terms
of they didn't want to do their goals in
the campaign were different than the
goals you want for your advertisers the
former so it just it didn't fit from a
brand perspective we thought it wasn't a
good thing to promote in our newsletter
and so we didn't want to promote it from
a moral standpoint but also we don't
want to upset our readers you know we
want people leaving because we're
advertising things that may be illegal
in the future or we're just recently
legalized and so we'd be very careful
with that so that is what we choose but
it ad deals are bespoke given its not
programmatic but we do like to work on
longer deals with with partners who have
longer time horizons so we can create
really compelling
krei campaigns and and as the ad team
has grown which it has recently we
actually call it the brand partnership
team because we do believe we're
building partnerships we're not just
selling ads we are planning out much
longer-term campaigns integrating
everything from content in the
newsletter to audio so podcast ads to
more experiential things so we testing
that as well and we want ad partners
we're willing to be experimental with us
and go along for that ride and and what
we found is there a lot of people who
like the way our brand resonates with
our readers and we're willing to do that
and so awesome what are the mistakes you
guys have made in building the business
right you guys as first-time
entrepreneurs you've had to raise
capital hire people manage people build
multiple products and all these
different things people would be crazy
to think that you've never made a
mistake like is there anything that
sticks out where you're like man we made
this mistake and then here's how we
corrected it yeah we've made every
mistake we possibly make toys oh no I
know you're telling the truth because by
the way every single person including
myself yes the same thing
no we've made every mistake the most
impactful mistakes always come down to
people so it's always you bring the
wrong person on for the wrong position
I've never regretted spending too long
to hire someone so I've never the only
hires we've regret are ones we made too
quickly so it's never been bad sale
let's interview one more candidate or
let's have one more interview with them
and you always want a balance so gonna
move quickly we want to make sure that
you know this happens this month because
that was the KPI we set to hire this
person they're gonna take another job
exactly yeah but I rather that than
bringing on a bad person I think people
don't understand how detrimental is to
bring on someone who is not a good fits
the team and the higher up they are the
more detrimental is and so it's a
challenge to bring on the best people
we've been fortunate that we've an
incredible team but it all comes down to
people and and bringing the wrong people
and putting them in the wrong position
giving them too much work to do not
focusing them that's the other big one
for me everything comes back to focus
right everything is focused and so you
know I ideas are 1% executions 99% or
whatever the cliché phrases and how do
you execute as you just focus and you
pick it's better to be good at a few
things then average the bunch of things
and so those are the two big ones it's
focusing people how do you spend your
day right it's talking about focus here
like you and your co-founder both are
still relatively small company right 35
employees give or take around there and
that means that you probably have
multiple hats versus if you had 200
people like how do you actually spend
your day on a day to day basis yeah so
it depends as it always does but alex is
more of the creative so he is way more
integrated in the content team helping
with the podcast help with you know
oversee content what's next with the
brand team social media so he's doing a
lot of that I'm overseeing the growth
team and product and tech and in sales
now obviously people are running those
but I'm making sure all of those
integrate on a day to day basis and
oversee more of the day-to-day but for
me personally what I try to do is put
myself in high leverage positions so
things that for whatever reason normally
it's not even because of my skill set
normally because my position
Bini someone else would be worse at that
job because they don't have executive
power to make a decision fast enough or
they can't get in touch with the right
people whatever it may be I try to put
myself in positions that other people
wouldn't be able to thrive in that
position if I think someone's better
than me at something I'm the first
person to bring them on to replace me I
mean that's that's like part of our jobs
as co-founders is to scale the team such
that we are mission critical and fewer
and fewer decisions so make fewer and
fewer decisions on a day-to-day basis
but feel as if we've scaled ourselves
such that we while not literally are in
each room making each decision because
we've hired the right people and train
them absolutely who do you look out and
admire in the media world that's it's a
good question I
I like the infatuation a lot okay I may
be bringing them up find out what's so
interesting that I just it's the
interesting thing about brand at least
for me is that it's hard to articulate
when a company has a brand people
resonate with but it's very easy to feel
okay you know when you see it yeah thing
like no one says hey at least my friends
don't go hey I love Yelp or I love
Google review I like I can't even tell
you other review sites because I am just
I am a hundred percent all in on when I
need help find the restaurant if the
infatuation just 100 percent and so I
think they're a great one I think with
the ROI and Jim and my cousin Axio this
is another really great one what do you
like about them I think that their
ability to find great talent have that
talent run each newsletter and and
verticalized the business that way and
scale it it's pretty admire herbal they
have taken on funding which has helped
them do it in a quicker way than then we
would have been able to but you know
it's a somewhat similar model everyone
compares us for both newsletter
companies very different target
demographic and I think very different
angles are you saying that access is
going after boomers I would say that
actually us is target is boomers I'm not
sure that's what they
say I think they would say you know Mike
if you like hey man I heard you guys are
for boomers I think they've given
everyone a hard time where you do not
actually I think they would say
executives is what they would say but
they are different
I think that again from the brand
perspective everything from logos the
voice etc there is a very distinct
difference between while there is some
overlap there's a very distinct
difference in who you're going after
which kind of allows people to
self-select right hey if you fit one
group versus another you're more likely
to actually gravitate towards the
content yeah right yeah no absolutely
and another one I like because I'm
picking some of these you know small or
at least Kirk I can't wait to tweet that
access is going after boomers go ahead
please don't quote me on that is I like
a BuzzFeed done so obviously BuzzFeed
was was lumped in with some these other
larger internet first even Facebook
first publishers perhaps but Jonah
Peretti just wrote this really great
blog post about how they're diversifying
revenue and their licensing a bunch of
content and I think it's really
interesting what they're doing so I'm
not you know I have a a soft spot in my
heart for some of these smaller
publishers but I think a bunch people
are out there doing a good job um it's
tough obviously the media industry has
been through a lot recently and and I
have a lot of respect for also the small
it leaks for the ones they're doing
independence like what were thoughts
doing a skiff is another one there's a
lot of people out there I like explain
to me what exactly he's doing there yeah
so they've built a b2b travel company so
they are trying to create content
they've subscription they have events I
think events are a big part of their
business and target everyone the travel
industry got it it's a publication and
events business that's focused on a very
specific verticalized business yeah
industry yeah and I think while
potentially the ceiling is lower I'm
very bullish on b2b publications so you
pick a target for him it's for the
travel industry maybe its retail digit a
does media and they also have moderate
retails they've done a few they're a
bunch of these out there and they just
cover it to death they keep on cover it
and then they serve very targeted
at those people for very high CPMs
because the right people it's all b2b so
people are putting their subscriptions
their company cards and then they have
events that people's companies are
paying for so it's very high dollar
amount and so I mean consumer media is
tough I I really do like the b2b space I
think it's again it's gonna be tough to
see those billion dollar exits in the
b2b space but from an expected value
standpoint I think those are great
companies and those are companies where
you can go out and do it we did raise a
million dollars raised one round and go
build a profitable media company and
then at that point once you've raised a
profitable company then you've all the
leverage of someone's to come in and
then fund the company and a later date
then sure go ahead you're still in
control
you're still profitable and you can pick
the right investors for your goals yeah
super interesting when you think about
kind of the modern media company
obviously with morning brew Axios etc
there's this a weird balance between the
brand the company and then the
individual writers themselves and people
wanting to subscribe to them right plan
is here in the room so pick on her but
she obviously works at fortune writes
term sheet and so some people are going
to subscribe for the fortune brand and
the term sheet brand and then some
people gonna subscribe to someone here
from polina you guys obviously have very
similar things how do you think about
that balance and like how much to
promote the business and brand versus
like the individual writers also
understanding that hey if we just say
like you know
Austin's newsletter and in Austin leaves
were like we're screwed yeah right so
like where's that balance coming yeah so
I'm not gonna be I'll give you a great
answer this thing we think about all the
time it's a challenge because you look
at the person who wrote polina's dues
letter before he left he wasn't you uh
yeah a few before he left and so yeah
it's tough clean it's better yeah I
agree
uh-hum but I'll tweet that please don't
read that but so I think it depends
right and you have to make sure it
aligns with what you're doing so going
back to a copy like barstool they're all
personality they've gone all in and
that's what they do
so that makes a lot of sense you look at
morning brew right we're trying to build
a brand as a company so I don't think it
would make sense to launch to have one
name behind morning brew for that reason
with that being said could we create sub
brands such as we have business casual
where Kenzie grant is a face of that
sure but I do think used to be careful
in how you do that and make sure they
are sub brands even term-sheet
sure is written by one person if that
person leaves people will leave with
them but it's fortune term-sheet
it's not you know whoever is the current
writer of term sheets term sheet caveat
all that is I believe people resonate
more with people than brands yeah and so
I think someone's gonna crack this code
and potentially it is someone like a sub
stack who has said we're gonna be the
the faceless publisher and we're gonna
go out there and we're gonna create an
infrastructure for these personalities
to build their own newsletters I think
it's interesting it's an interesting
model if there's obviously lots of
difficulties there it's it's tough but
again it's it's a challenge because
people do resonate with people more than
brands and I think that will only
continue in the future
with social first with Instagram with
Twitter sub statutes so like Marshall is
a great example barstool essentially has
created a WWF right like that's really
what they've recreated in a very very
thoughtful way and I think a lot of
people are kinda like that's mass chaos
going on over there it's not at all it's
like they're super super on top of what
they're doing and have been very
strategic and and it's worked very well
but do you think that they can pull off
the personality first type content
because of the type of content that
they're creating meaning that it's more
comedy based more entertainment than it
is like actual news right meaning if you
listen to some of their podcasts
whatever they're actually you're not
going there to read like the Astros beat
the Yankee no [ __ ] the Astros the
Yankees beat the Astros cuz the Astros
are cheaters but you're not going there
for the score of the game Yeah right
instead of what you're doing is you're
going to hear the personal opinions of
these individuals right like the content
or brand
promise is different than say ESPN which
I want to go in here you know what was
the score what are the stats etc could
the ESPN's of the world transition well
or is that just too hard for them to do
at this point so III think what what
we're seeing is people don't really care
about as much about this at least from
the engagement standpoint don't care as
much about the scores don't care as much
about even the the longer highlights
right
I follow house of highlights I want the
amazing Omar de CrossFit well yeah he
crushed a hey and yeah it's a
interesting that he left and and we'll
see how that plays out but even so he
went to ESPN right was it he is it I
didn't even know they I believe I could
be right believe what the SportsCenter
and I think if you go to sports centers
Twitter he it says this is Omar yeah so
he left that's like the free agency of
the year right that yeah yeah it was big
and so they're going more about Joe we
gotta find out how much they paid that
dude they they ESPN and Sports Center
were like our business sucks Hausa
Heights is crushing us pay that kid
whatever he wants yeah and so we'll see
I do think to Madi mo more on how much
they pay you I'm sure it's a lot how
about you think how much do you think if
you're yeah how should I don't know I
have no idea over/under two million
dollars a year
I'd say under but not so I'm going over
well you know why if you're ESPN and you
lose on social in today's day and age
you accelerate your demise and two
million dollars or more is nothing to
ESPN to stay the leader in sports yeah i
two million dollars a lot of money
hosted memes at videos the internet but
he's probably the best in the sports
he's good he's good as OB agency tell
house of highlights continues I'm sure
they'll be fine but anyway back to your
question I think it's tough rights gotta
be in the DNA and I'm sure even a bar a
bar stool right everyone I assume anyone
who let's not call them barstool sports
let's call them barstool because not
sports it's entertainment right and I
think that's where people get so angry
is people don't realize they're not a
news company it's it's it's
entertainment it's fun it's not chaos
its manufacture chaos so my whole thing
was
March of 16 I think it's when they took
the money from churnin right
I wrote a thing on media they were
invited 15 million dollars and I said
Dave Portnoy and his secret plan to
build a billion-dollar media company and
I was like look it's gonna be a billion
dollar company and literally people were
like you are the biggest [ __ ] idiot
in the world and my whole point was no
you guys are missing the fact that the
future of media has nothing to do with
the quality of the content it has
everything to do with the audience and
if people are paying attention and
there's eyeballs there and there that
fanatical they'll be able to do all
kinds of stuff and the thing that I
missed in the analysis was I actually
thought that they were gonna go faster
outside of the entertaining sports
content so I was like oh you can see
barstool news you could see this like
all these different things they tested
some of it but I think what happened is
like when they tried it it didn't really
resonate as much as just like no just
doubled triple down on like sports
related type content or kind of cultural
related content and so what that begs
the question of is it sports and culture
like the wringer barstool accessor
it's just that type of industry is open
to that type of content or could you
like could you build a barstool like a
media company for politics for example
or is it just doesn't work because
there's no way to rebuild that type of
DNA and that manufactured chaos etcetera
in the politics industry yeah I think
it's gotta be done in its own way I mean
one could argue that pod save America or
the crooked guys have have done that
right it just did interesting it's just
not gonna be as as vulgar or or whatever
words you know use beers man it's all
your beers will go down as the greatest
campaign of all time but but I think
what you said before about your your
billion-dollar Nelson bar stool I don't
think that just media that's consumer in
general for sure right I think there was
this huge convergence of content in
commerce and then a David Perel but Dave
and I co-wrote this piece nine months
ago I was actually talking to someone
today I would double down on that
on which part so commerce you know these
direct consumer brands their commodities
most these companies are just a
commoditized product
a mattress is a mattress right don't
tell Casper sorry hey hey you know most
of these are commodities and everyone
launched and they said okay we're gonna
use this unique little this little
you'll get Facebook ads or whatever it
may be there's a shiny more this little
attack but the end of the day it's so
easy to spin up one of these and this is
not to discredit in these companies
right some of these have built really
great companies but for the most part
it's very very the consumer space is so
challenging and so I do think this idea
of media companies and media company can
be a very very broad statement and
you're a media company right so personal
I'm into my comedic than a media company
or media and and and I think everyone
else some extent is media you have an
Instagram following you have a Twitter
following and so you you walk into the
liquor store now cos amigos that's a
Clooney right Ryan Reynolds right he
launches right proper twelve
yeah it's McGregor [ __ ] Jerry launch
haha fat Jewish who's actually coming on
business casual shameless plug I think
next week launched babe rose a so but
yes old it come on arm anybody's I think
I don't know how much it was but ABM
ever I'm sure it wasn't sheet like so
here here's you ready for this the fat
Jew [ __ ] Jerry and Dave Portnoy are
worth more money
individually than almost everyone listen
to this podcast how's your life going
know it's a think about that for a
second it's true it also shows the the
perils or or how in jeopardy news is or
I think a lot of the the media industry
is because again media is just so broad
and and people want to connect with
people and then by there's iliyan beers
is a great example
I didn't even follow up that much but
it's it's Dave and this guy going back
and forth and they sold a million and a
half dollars of swag that's insane and
literally just said zillion beers in a
bunch of different ways and the way that
he marketed it was he would basically
turn on the selfie video camera in his
apartment chug beers and scream buy buy
buy and then smash the beer can on his
head and they sold a million and half
dollars in nine days
yeah you know it's another one I
actually really like his complex right
because complex what they've done is
other media companies out there say hey
we're we're bullish on podcasts we're
getting the podcast industry
I don't believe unless you're Spotify
you can be bullish on podcasts right why
because what complex has said is we are
built bullish on building brands and
these brands the best way to do it well
for them is video right there saying
okay for us video is the best way to do
it and they're gonna do you know Joel of
Pumas thing or I don't even know the
guys name but I've watched 10 of these
hot ones as a video is the best way
we're gonna build that brand and then
what do they do they sell that hot sauce
right you know barstool was bullish on
podcast but they weren't bullish on
podcasts as a medium per se they were
bullish on podcast ability to build a
brand and so there are all these
companies out there a lot of companies
out there are saying hey we're bullish
on product X video podcast but those get
saturated what's not saturated is a
brand and so leveraging a brand and to
your point before leveraging as many
ways as possible complex builds a brand
plate monetize on YouTube I have spa
other native sponsorship deals in
addition to the YouTube sponsorship they
license that content they sell hot sauce
they make money off each brand in ten
different ways so it's not just hey
we're gonna launch video it's know we're
launching a brand and it's a video first
brand so Business Insider sold 88
percent stake for three hundred forty
three million dollars I just looked it
up to confirm yeah which means that
barstool sports when they had their look
had the recent sale is worth more money
than Business Insider
yeah it's well do you think about yeah
but I can almost guarantee you if you go
and ask somebody under the age of I
don't know 35 32 right which one they
read more they'll say barstool they
actually can they actually consume more
content yeah I'm partial and also they
resonate with more barstool
personalities they know more barstool
brand they've bought more barstool emerg
they've they've interact with the brand
in more ways I will all say I think
barstool you know they were doing great
but then the sports Bay I don't know if
you read the the blog post that Erica
and nerdini put out who's the CEO of our
still put out titled I have 450 million
reasons to to be a token CEO or
something like that
people [ __ ] hated on them for
bringing in this the female CEO and she
completely savaged everybody yeah she's
amazing and what what I yeah what would
they have done there is it's just
incredible but I do think there was a
bit of luck there with the sports
gambling thing and that was just such a
perfect fit but ok so this is a good
example is it luck that they got the
sports gambling to be start become
legalized and that opened up that path
or is it more of they would have been
successful in any manner because they
have that audience and then when they
saw this opportunity they just kind of
navigated that way because they realized
that that was huge yeah so I actually
when I first started morning Bruce
someone told me a saying and it was do
everything you can to increase your luck
surface area which is a great saying and
that's what barstool did they increase
their luck surface area now did they hit
a potentially hit a very high end of
that luck surface area have at the
sports gambling thing maybe but yeah
you're a hundred percent right they put
themselves in that position to succeed I
think a lot of other brands are gonna do
the same thing where who knows what the
next big thing is but also with with you
know marijuana and becoming legalized in
more and more States could bar still
have capitalize on that a hundred
percent I'm sure they could have had
plans they do have plans I who who knows
what what's next or what opportunities
coming about but the people who are you
know building but if they didn't build a
brand and they didn't build
personalities they certainly wouldn't be
able to capitalize so taking nothing
away from them they built the brand they
build personalities and it's allowed
them to succeed does it change the way
like as these brands become more popular
personalities become more popular does
it change the way that content is
created but can we still live in a world
where we have unbiased news or content
given that the rewards in digital or
more
personalities more around opinions kind
of salacious hot takes etc it's a good
question I I don't know but what I do
know is I think this is actually going
to help the New York Times the world why
because you look at people trust the New
York Times and so if the more and more
people start to not trust other people
well I'll take a step back
a certain subset of people trust the New
York Times and the people who trust the
New York Times really trust the New York
Times
I think 30% of the New York Times
revenues from cooking would yeah they're
cooking up really something like that
yeah or maybe cooking and crosswords
yeah right
what does that have to do with a new
political coverage it does it but they
have the distribution and you trust them
and so yet they've probably built I've
never used the cooking app they've
probably built the incredible app so I'm
not taking anything away from them
that's so good the food just appears
that magic that's a billion dollar brand
right there but that's why I think it's
such a barbell right it's all gonna come
to the top the these the brands that
people trust the brands will resonate
with are gonna crew more and more value
and then I do think there's an
opportunity for the indie publisher the
Ben Thompson the the the person who's
doing a really good job to make a great
living I think that's an awesome
opportunity but I think a lot of people
are gonna get stuck in the middle of the
barbell which is no one really cares
about what you're saying you can't
monetize that maybe you've raised too
much capital to sell and you're stuck
and I think we're seeing that in
consumer from with with direct consumer
we're seeing it media will continue to
see it media I am really into to see
what the fallout is because there's been
some media consolidation and I'm not
talking about like Disney and I'm
talking more about some of the
publishers and so there's been some
consolidation but that feels like it's
like a a stepping stone to what's
actually gonna happen and so what's
gonna happen with other publishers and
we'll see here's a hot take for you Ben
Thompson's not an indie publisher he's
an influencer I would agree Riya and if
you think about the
in the sense of that line is getting
very very blurred yep right because the
quote-unquote indie publisher of the
past now looks more like an influencer
but they're still either monetizing or
creating content like the indie
publisher used to do and so if you look
at like a Kylie Jenner she built a
physical products hold it through to an
audience like what's the difference
between Ben Thompson super high quality
you know analysis of some tech company
or strategy versus Kylie Jenner posting
a picture of her ass like actually not
that much if both of them are trying to
monetize no i yeah i Jenner ass in there
because I wanted to see a reaction and
you I'm not gonna comment on that but
I'm getting head shake from polina as
well so that means that was a great
comment good but no it's the cons of the
commerce thing right people or media
companies and Ben Thompson I pay I think
it's 120 bucks a year if he built
something of a higher dollar amount I
would pay for that too I mean and these
staggered media models Webb Smith's
another one does a great job it's it's
staggering right and so I'm gonna get
Webb in here man you do yeah he's great
and so but what he's done is and he
should speak to it much better I can is
he built a paid newsletter which is I
think 100 200 bucks whatever and that
has a pretty high top a funnel and then
he has some executive forum which is you
know maybe 10x that or maybe nineties
that allison ology yeah yeah so l 999
yeah and so you know for people's that
willingness to pay they join that and
then I'm sure he's doing other things
for people's willingness to pay as
10,000 or 50 and maybe I don't know
maybe that is consulting I know so and
it's not just him it's all these people
and so I think these models there is if
you are unbelievable there are endless
opportunities for you to monetize
yourself monetize your content monetize
your network if you're not I think
things will be very very challenging for
the other 98% of people but this is true
not only in the media world this is also
true anything kind of what you're
getting at here is like this influencer
world where you know the rock is
probably the best example of this right
now he's the most recognized actor in
the
world he sold us the wrestling stuff he
now has a production company he's
produced things like some gladiator show
or whatever he's got going on he's got
to do I don't know three to five movies
a year that are all pretty big
productions then he's got his tequila
company that he's launching and he's
good online you're like dude this dude
what was the jay-z line like I'm not a
businessman I'm a businessman exactly
yeah like that's essentially what we're
seeing but again if you compare Ben
Thompson Kylie Jenner and the rock they
all look very different but the
strategies do that same
yeah and potentially not potentially the
rock has a higher you know total
addressable market or and he can launch
more products but I'm not sure if that's
what it's about right at some to some
extent it's about living the life you
want about doing the work you want to do
and the tools are out there I can
strongly guess that this is exactly what
Ben Thompson wants to do and I think a
lot of there's a way bigger business if
he wanted to do other things but he
probably doesn't want to do other things
yeah and that's so many people on sub
stack or with these communities it's you
have the flexibility in the freedom to
do whatever you want I mean it's not
it's not a revolutionary concept right
goes back to even Tim Ferriss is 4-hour
workweek and all of that but all these
tools Shopify sub stack stripe they've
all made it incredibly easy now
potentially too easy to become a
billion-dollar brand like some of these
direct to consumers right the push the
direct consumer a lot of that was was
helped by you know logistics and Shopify
and stripe and all the and Facebook ads
and all of this right and so people
thought okay that allows you to create
these direct consumer companies maybe
not right maybe these companies aren't
meant to be billion dollar brands
because there's so much opportunity for
it's maybe gotten too democratized now
everyone can do it right you can make
your own Candle Company and start
selling candles tomorrow probably you
know you could it's not that hard and my
big thesis around this is it it lends
itself to Tanisha's and so if you can
find a deep niche like Ben has like web
has like you having crypto you will
succeed and I think niches are way
deeper than people think and you can
provide and
this value to people and go up that
staggering willingness to pay and launch
the low AOV the middle the high and
really extract as much value as you want
to from your niche now certainly some
niches are larger than others but they
are way way deeper in the internet and
all these platforms are showing us just
how deep these niches are and just how
much people can monetize how do you
think about physical products right we
saw like publishers like quote imp and
then air quotes Kylie Jenner lip kit the
rock the tequila
BuzzFeed had a whole labs thing right
they think so candles or calendar you
know tasty alright yeah all this stuff
how do you guys think about physical
products that's something that you've
looked at would go into or kind of how
do you think about that yeah so our
team's gonna make fun of me because I've
been talking about launching a sock
brand for a while a sock yeah so so not
we haven't actually thought about it I'm
just a big sock fan let's think about it
right now all right
what kind of socks you have on umm
bombas bombas yeah you're like a
high-end sock I'm a low-end suck I
always wear Nikes usually you know why
why so we might want to get dunked on
what about the sock right why socks
high-margin
I don't think anyone's built a brand in
the business sock space there resonates
with Millennials okay so you wear to
work they are well it's not doesn't
replenish in the same way that
toothpaste or shaving cream does you do
want to refresh your socks it can't wear
holes in the shocks yeah again is this
high margin and I also like dress socks
or like everyday socks oh it was it both
I love people are gonna give me 90 ever
at Muybridge even on this now wait but
so is the idea that you build a brand
and everyone like kind of like so take
polo for example yeah like polo is hey
we put our little horse you know guy on
here and now all of a sudden it's a polo
shirt shirt yes but we put the brand
people on a bike as a polo shirt
versus let's say a shirt that has like
really cool designs on it I bike because
the design not because of the brand
which bucket did the socks go into is it
more the brand or the actual
design of the sock we get we have to
test it but we want to do fun socks
right morning Bruce fun witty I think we
could do like a business casual sock
right yeah yeah goes on sock what give
me what I know you thought about this
give me what ideas gonna come and take
it what's the worst idea you had so no
one will take able to give us an idea of
the type of soccer time I I can't give
away I can't go back all right when he
launches a billion dollar sock brand I
want credit for pushing them to do this
but odds are the paint product we
launched will not be saw get down the
record made that clear I've been
overruled that will be a solid project
at some point a sock brand for myself I
do all of a sudden morning brew launches
like pocket protectors are stupid and
not socks I'll be so mad no no I think
what we launched when we think about
paid products and has to further
people's career it has to you know
continue education further in their
career something that is not news
something that is additive that you feel
like after a year's worth of spending
you know whether it's a hundred dollars
or a thousand dollars you feel as if
you've extracted value and you have
actionable takeaways and so that's we're
working towards is what's something we
can provide for people that they feel
like after consuming the content on me
obviously content vague so whatever that
means people feel like they've gained
something out of it professionally
personally whatever it may be and
actually one of the general partners and
injuries and hardwoods wrote a great
blog post title a thousand fans versus
100 fans have you saw this oh yeah and
so when you look at a lot of media
companies are out there thinking in the
thousand fan vein hey and influencers as
well
hey you like me a lot and twitch was
built off this I yeah I'm not a big
sports person but I believe anyway you
know give me like a dollar two dollars
not out of your own self-interest
because you like me and support me and
you want to see me succeed that's an
option I really like the other one which
was the hundred true fans model which is
we are going to give you true value that
you were gonna pay for L of self
interest because it's furthering you and
bettering your career and that is
something that we believe we have the
right to play you know to be a part of
and to make a play there and so we'll
see we're not rushing it again we have
no timeline we're not gonna launch
anything until we feel as if we're in
the right you know we have the ability
and we have a great product but that's
definitely what we're thinking if we
were launched something paid how do we
get people to pay for something out of
their self-interest not because they
support morning brew mm-hmm
Bitcoin would your thoughts I was hoping
you wouldn't ask me about this Omaha how
you gonna walk in here and I'm not gonna
I was actually I play in a poker game
with a bunch of that the Bitcoin guys
the guys in the block yeah a few of
these other you know crypto and eToro
and if you have other ones and they
always they they're trying to push yeah
I do own some Bitcoin okay no because I
don't have a good diversified portfolio
okay it's good answer I I think it's
it's interesting I wish I invested five
years ago everyone does but I don't have
a strong enough stands take an opinion
okay it would it be fair to say at what
you said you're 25 yes that it is
increasing in popularity among kind of
your friend group meaning more of like
demographically or it is decreasing it's
stagnant like what do you see I'm
fascinated by the idea that there's lots
of people talking about like 25 in under
I got a brother who's I think John's
like 23 and like I read all the stuff
and I go talk to him and like his
opinion is literally the opposite of
what the media is writing about so I
have a 25 year old right here he's gonna
tell us all the secrets so obviously
there was that big boom we have when
Bitcoin went to 20,000 dollars a coin
all your friends became degenerate
gamblers yeah which is when I bought
that coin 50% no I wasn't that bad but
not that good
um I I would say it's pretty stagnant
now okay I just know a good thing yeah
it's better than 2017 when everyone was
buying it at you know fifty thousand ten
thousand I would agree um I do think
cash is going away so let's let's make
interesting oh you're not necessarily
like hardcore Bitcoin believer but
you're a believer in the legacy world
will change yes doesn't really go away
but it just we go cashless exactly I
think we're gonna go
list now who-who owns that space I I
have not enough research whether is it
you know one of these FinTech companies
a credit-card company which coin may it
be I don't know ever was hot on
aetherium before and I know that was
they had different use cases but I do
think we're heading in that direction I
just don't have enough knowledge or
spent the time to be causing that
Bitcoin is the right coin yes for hum I
think we should start a morning brew
coin we were I was just gonna ask if
you're ever gonna start a crypto
newsletter but morning brew coin you're
like jumping to level 301 or 401 I ain't
so at the top of morning brew we have a
ticker and we have gold this is me
really embarrassed hey we have the Dow
we have the S P we have Nasdaq we have
gold and they really the 10-year and
maybe one other I came over it's five or
six which I read every day I should know
yeah and everyone's like you gotta add
crypto you gotta add crypto and so we'll
see but that'll be a big step if and
when we had crypto it's the top of
Mordor that's the first step but we did
think all these ICO jokes whenever was I
see it like what was happening but then
all the fraud you know [ __ ] the fan and
early alright this isn't fun anymore
what it was funny when you when people
were like hey man I know that guy that
guy let me put up a website and just
raise 300 million dollars so I'm like
wait some I just came fifty million what
the hell are you guys investing yeah and
then you're like oh wait think I
disappeared with the money never mind
yeah so that wasn't very funny we
weren't gonna make that joke but yeah I
think the financial system is evolving I
just I don't know I can't say I'm
bullish on Bitcoin but I own it
so I also can't say I'm embarrassed I
hope it goes through a million you're
gonna be the president United States for
that politically correct answer
aliens believer or non-believer Oh
believer why Fermi paradox you know it's
if you read that yeah yeah it's us 200
plus people this that's probably the
most common answer right and it's also
probably most rational it's math it's
just like probability is so high it's
also a very similar argument that we're
we're in a simulation you think so yeah
a lot of us as we are I trust how to so
how do we break out that's a good I
don't have the answer to that one
are you ok alright you just mentioned
Elan so we're gonna go there are you
like a Tesla fanboy okay so I would say
prepping I can I get C's like oh [ __ ]
make sure I answer this one correctly so
high level yes I think Elan is a net
positive for the world
he's Gregory yeah Advent what what's his
expression you know like basically
create a better society through
technology and and the the what I think
is most interesting about on must people
think he is this I like like an
unbelievable engineer no it's the
business models that business models are
fascinating what he does is he says hey
I want to create an electric car future
ever and has electric cars and so most
people say all right well let start
making electric cars he realize you
can't do that so instead let's go out
there and let's make the super what was
the original roadster yeah and let's
sell that let's sell to rich people and
that'll get make it sexy make it cool
and then we'll sell you know we'll do
the the Model S which is more afford
well still not affordable but you know
100 grand so more people can buy it and
then we'll innovate each time will
innovate our battery technology more and
more and then we'll have the model 3 is
one is now and then we'll go even
further down the line Wolff affordable
car
same thing with SpaceX right we want to
go to Mars
you can't just raise money go to Mars no
one's gonna pay for that well he
probably could raise money to go to Mars
out of the gate but he knew that that
would be a bad idea
yeah so instead you know satellites and
let's innovate on Russia pick technology
every single time and so he's very first
principles yeah very first principles
yeah yeah and that's and it this is all
by the way this is not original thinking
this is all the Tim urban PC is
incredible I've probably read that c-raf
four-part series like seven times which
is longer than the book so I think Tim
urban is a real person so supposedly
yeah supposing my co-founder sat next to
him on an airplane I've emailed back and
forth and once or twice we're trying to
get him to design morning group joking
because I know he's a real person I
think plant is talked with them etcetera
but I just feel like a guy named Tim
urban is the exact person who ends up
being like an urban legend and
a whole bunch of people who are writing
our data I've seen into a TED talk which
is very funny and very good but we got
to get him on business casual we got to
get him we had to sign with him a
morning brew back to your question a lot
so in that positive some of the stuff
he's done Hobbes shouldn't done but huge
net poverty will you ever tweet out
funding secured I'm waiting hi nobody's
gonna [ __ ] I'm waiting for a start-up to
announce their funding by tweeting out
funding secured we don't plan on raising
capital anytime soon however that's not
a bad idea we might not raise money just
to do that like I just think about
that's like a layup or move for a
startup and I'm shocked then no one's
thought of that one yet yeah I think
people are staying away from that but
yeah someone's got to embrace that
that's good that's a go under there's
enough of psychos out this I'm good all
right what's your favorite book and you
get asked me a question then we're done
cool I'll let you out of the dungeon
that's what i'ma start calling this
place look this has got nothing like a
prison cell I'll give you two because
one I just read recently and then I'll
give you one that I read pretty
frequently I just read the Bob Iger book
oh yeah incredible really I try my best
to not read books written in the last
five 10 years just prefer books that
have stood the test of time and you know
you're not reading it because they're
they've had a great PR strategy but I
think Disney's fascinating and I read
the Eiger book and it was incredible so
I would recommend reading that and the
other ones deep work Cal Newport why do
I know this it's pretty famous book yeah
what is this about it's about doing T
Park basic idea is that in today's
society a society the most valuable
skill you can have is you really learn
things quickly the best way to learn
think quicks things quickly is getting
the deep work as fast as possible
oh and so it's it's how can you get in a
deep work and it goes through some
examples of if you were you know it
gives the most extreme example if you're
a researcher you may disconnect
completely from society for six months
or or some people just like don't have
social media toll and then there's
people like JK Rowling who she when she
was writing at Harry Potter like
didn't like I'm gone I'm gonna go write
this book or these seven books out of a
there are and so she you know went ahead
and did that but then it goes she write
them like really fast to I don't know
but I wouldn't she did yeah okay go
ahead yeah but and then goes all the
downs like okay
you you work in a normal 9 to 5 how can
you find time with met nine to five to a
carve-out deep work and and I talked
about at morning bro all the time it we
spend so much time doing shallow work
doing low leverage tasks because you're
inundated with slack or email and that's
all playing defense and so you have to
force yourself to play offense to set a
schedule and it's all about going back
it's focused right it's one of the most
important things if you don't set
yourself up for success however you want
to do it you're gonna end up being
beholden to everyone else size yourself
doing everyone else's checklist doing
work for everyone else you have to be
very strict with your time and I think
that may at times come off as
off-putting or unfriendly but you just
can't grab coffee with everyone you can
say no is ok yeah you have to say no
it's a great thing I need to be
comfortable saying no and so deep works
great I've read two or three times now
and I would recommend everyone to read
it I've never asked some of this
question before now I'm interested
because you just said all that what is
the way that you communicate internally
and externally you use email text slack
Twitter DM Instagram DMS paper airplanes
whatever else people are using today
yes I've started to simplify a lot so i
download instagram probably one day a
week and shall I check in and delete it
just so I yeah I I'm really not on
Instagram or I deleted my facebook ok
just it's just too much too many signal
I just I got that from a 25 the Facebook
being um Twitter DM Instagram you
redownload it every week it takes 30
seconds yeah but still I just don't to
open the app I like yeah oh okay
it's like on a Sunday night I'll go I'll
download it check out some videos and
I'm like why do I even have this and
delete it again twitter twitter DM z--
are a disaster it's so hard and that's
why this took so long to book because I
take five days there's the only person
that's worse than me I'm really yeah
like two days late hey uh and I was like
man yes I found somebody I'm bad I'm bad
I just miss I'd like if I if I if it
goes down
I just never scroll back far enough to
get it there's no mark as unread the
discoverability is terrible Sam with
text though the same a text same with
slack
I hate slack we used lack at work I
don't you see I can't stand and the
reason why I can't stand it is because
well there's a few reasons first people
when people write an email you take time
you write the email you proofread it and
it takes time therefore most people can
if that email woulda been a slack they
would just send it but a lot of times in
writing your email you realize oh I
actually know the answer this or it
takes time and it's there's a little
friction there and that friction makes
you consider other alternatives such as
googling it or figuring out yourself
also in slack people talk stream of
conscious so they might say hey Austin
next that they don't enter I have a
question enter instead just asking what
they want or telling you what they want
and then going back to discoverability
someone sends me a slice let's say
something important but all time to deal
with it what do i do do i mark as unread
do i like there's no there's no
prioritization at all there's no way to
just like put it in in like a folder
which an email I have I love email
there's no like I can't wait for slack
to listen to this and then say no
they're not advertising on the podcast
yeah I'm sorry Butterfield vamp I just
can't get behind I don't know but all
the reason all those reasons are
actually very true and it's very kind of
Bezos esque in terms of like he says
look we start out every meeting you have
to write it's like three or six page
thing the person lead in the meeting and
everyone there starts the meeting by
literally Rita with this person wrote
and so I hey somebody took something
that you're about to meet with it took
the time to write this like she wanted
to get pretty seriously and I bet if
they know that everyone at the meeting
is gonna read it they're gonna take the
time to write it really well yeah a
hundred percent you have to add friction
to communication I think the thought for
a while was Oh as little friction as
possible slack and all these chatting
apps and for what it's worth it's also
our fault for not building a good you
know set of rules or infrastructure
around slack but it's just so easy to do
just like having that Instagram app my
phone and so he just click on it
having slack it's just so easy default
to
you know I don't want to go through that
friction of opening an email a subject
line I so much rather just open this
thing up and type away and I will go
back and open up my phone and I will
have 50 slack messages and he'll me will
actually be important and the problem is
the answer will be more than zero so I
need a siphon through those find the
important ones figure out how do I store
that information it's so yeah not a
slack person so I try to do everything
through email and it's funny how when
you force people to send you emails how
many fewer emails you get than slacks
and potentially some of those problems
aren't being solved I would guess 99%
those three being solved the person just
actually solving it themselves versus
putting the work on other people
somebody needs to create a autoresponder
for Twitter DMS that says hey can you
please email me yeah I bet 50% of the
dm's I get that I respond to
that's my response I don't even
acknowledge what they said I should say
hey can you email me here's my email
because I'm actually interested in what
they're saying but this whole thing of
like oh if I start talking to you then I
go do something out like it's yeah send
it all if anyone is still listening for
this please build that or send us if you
send us a link or something yeah
somebody I would love that I would love
I see I don't want to shut off in
Twitter DM because I love Twitter I
committed to you know building following
on Twitter begin in 2019 and it's the
bit so I'll talk about high leverage
activities
nothing is higher leverage than Twitter
you to interact with the smartest people
on the planet people not on Twitter
don't understand they don't know that
are on Twitter like duh like like why
you tell me what I already know yeah
right it's just the leverage you can
create and I've met some of those two
incredible people friends co-worker
you're just like really really smart
people we work route using Twitter for
me it's it's brand marketing it's what
are you guys do used to slide in
someone's DMS you know like want a job
no no we just posed hey job descriptions
yeah and people just retweet or yeah
there are people who all see it all like
oh that person interesting D and them or
maybe they won't want to work at morning
brew but they'll know someone yeah so I
mean friends co-workers it you name it
you know side business partners
everything has all been
you know done through Twitter so I love
Twitter but dm's just terrible
yeah they're gonna improve it I got
faith yeah all right we really
sidetracked there what uh what one
question you have for me to finish this
up hits me on Bitcoin oh man not a
question but in a minute 30 or less I
might do it in three sentences perfect
probably 95 plus percent of your wealth
is denominated in a single currency if
that currency fails you're screwed and
any other fiat currency that you store
your wealth in is being debased away
every single year but I know about one
that's not okay that's really it
right it's very simple but to your point
I think a lot of people make it much
more complex than it really is right
because it's almost like once you know
the pitch a Bitcoin you're like oh
that's it but why Bitcoin why not why
not pump coin because if the US dollar
failed you would never trust the US
government with any other currency we
see this in countries all time right so
like for example venezuelan bolivia are
its hyper-inflated away I don't care
what currency they come out with next no
one's trusting it Yeah right
same thing here is when Bitcoin was the
first to be created currency is the one
thing where first mover advantage really
really matters especially once you get
the network effect going and so if
Bitcoin fails my prediction is that no
other digital currency that is separated
from a sovereign nation will work so
basically we have Bitcoin as the one
chance at separation of state money if
it doesn't work I don't care who
launches what after that the human
species will not trust a software led
non-sovereign currency so it's kind of
this like weird first mover advantage
network effect brand awareness thing
that like here we go now there's all
these other things like stable coins and
also other stuff I look at those as like
really what they are is they're taking
digital currencies and they're kind of
like it's an evolution of the fiat
currency because ultimately this isn't
about technology it's about the monetary
policy so that's like the big
misconceptions everyone's really worried
about you know what technology am I
gonna use well eventually every currency
is gonna be digital instead what you
have to do is you to make a decision on
the monetary policy so u.s. monetary
policy is obviously one thing you know
China Russia India all around the world
but they all have a very similar
framework which is they use inflation
and interest rate cuts in order to drive
economic activity well that's great for
the top 50 percent or less it's really
bad for the bottom 50 percent less of a
population you can do that for a really
long time like literally decades and
decades of decades but eventually that
game ends I don't know if that's like
next year or 200 years from now yeah but
literally every global reserve currency
in the world has failed other than the
US dollar so far because they debase
dawei the currency like what is it like
we're doing the same thing and so
they're like there's just weird and I
still got a business experiment right
like there's this deflationary thing
that has a disinflationary monetary
schedule that like is a digital currency
it's actually got like pretty big
adoption if you think about 11 years in
you know more than 1% of world's
population has it access to it or
exposure
it's got shot yeah so no probability
successes but like it's above zero yeah
so it feels like your your lesson
bullish on Bitcoin then you are bearish
on every other currency and therefore if
you're bears never their currency and
every other cryptocurrency not named
Bitcoin then the default is just you
know it may not be Bitcoin that's not
Bitcoin it's nothing so yeah so
basically like well it's two things so
definitely bearish on fiat currencies in
general now that's not like I have some
original thought like you said yeah it's
like we'll just look at history right
like debasing the currency ends up
leading to the demise of the currency so
like that's me delivering five plus
thousand years yeah wasn't that happen
and like if we think that were smarter
than history like were the idiots in the
room so I think that generally falls in
that bucket but then when you look at
like what is the solution I do think
that this idea of two things so one
separation of state money and to triple
entry accounting like
applying those two things together in
the unique way that bitcoins done it
it's like it has this legitimate shot
the scale right because I think the what
would be scary is like oh we all know
about something but it's actually built
to scale and this is where you get the
like MySpace's of the world etc right
that's why our Facebook and come along
or you know whatever
22:23 search engines before Google etc
those are tech problems this isn't a
tech problem this is a monetary policy
problem and so when you see it that way
I think all of a sudden you're fine
the the woman who cleans the place just
came and that means were working hard we
should get paid overtime today no but
but I think that the monetary policy
part is lost on a lot of people and it's
like a weird subject like how many
people actually understand u.s. monetary
policy or like fiat currency like across
not many no actually scary thought like
the central bankers might not even
understand my I'll leave ever with one
stat I need to look up how many times
but I think that the Federal Reserve has
tried to predict GDP growth on a in the
quarter to come so like that the next
quarter over 200 times like 10 or 50
times or something
they have gone zero for 250 times right
they've never gotten it right now we're
talking about they may say one point
eight percent ends up being one point
seven or something like that right so
they can be close but they've never
nailed it and so it just goes back to
show like humans are pretty stupid right
and in terms of some of this stuff and
so they're trying to make predictions
about things in the future that just
aren't predictable so we'll see what
happens
cool all right are you believer uh held
I failed I will buy a bit more Bitcoin
okay that's fine just do $10 so you
don't get mad if you lose it listen
where can uh where can people get in
touch with you and then where can they
sign up for the newsletters
yeah so I just said I'm not an Instagram
anymore so I actually do an Instagram
but Twitter so Austin underscore reef
rief
so that's me and then you can go to
morning brew com sign for morning brew
and you can just Google retail brew
emerging tech Peru business casual
obviously business casual is everywhere
you can download a podcast Spotify Apple
wherever else you want to listen to your
podcast
cool alright man thanks so much sweet
[Music]